pas simple elle quittait peu alpha 5
je suis ton temps des futurs ivoire je
suis sûr qu'il vaut mieux le futur il
faut qu'ils arrivent
ce grenier a réussi sa mission et a
modifié le cas c'est la guerre devrait
bientôt son nom pendant est-ce que c'est
toujours la guerre est là et là c'est
toujours le cas oui je libérer la
fréquence quand je peux je crois que ça
n'a pas marché ça petit futur on
arrêtait de m'appeler comme ça ça n'a
aucun sens
nous avons récupéré les landes à lui les
chinois ont envoyé une nano électro
marine dans le passé une commande revers
la force de la porte qui ils sont très
forts en contrefaçon et copiera très
certainement l'apparence du père de
grenier pour s'approcher de lui
[Musique]
nous allons encore
quant à christine j'arrive monsieur
grenier oui avec un accent aigu
[Musique]
vous devez retourner dans le passé pour
empêcher cette nano électro machine
d'auteur ferrée entre le jeune grenier
son père pendant qu'il découvre les jeux
vidéo
sinon la résistance n'existera jamais et
il y aura des bambins danger vos rénale
mourir attend des commandes en est là la
guerre est finie renier premier devoir
c'est le jeu mais je te dis jamais tu
ressens viens te sors un peu la regarde
ce que j'ai terminator sur nes sorti en
mais précise semaine dernière ce jeu
bref on y va
c'est parti ouais ok je vais aller
m'asseoir un petit peu plus loin moi pas
besoin de présenter les films terminator
et c'est un des grands classiques des
années 90 le film qui a propulsé choisi
comme superstar d'action et cameron
comme un réalisateur d'exception les
jeux terminator ils sont arrivés assez
tard finalement le premier film est
sorti en 84 et pourtant vu le film on
aurait pu se dire que c'était le bon
plan pour faire des jeux d'action est
maintenant le premier à être sorti
c'était en 90 surdose six ans après la
sortie du film quand même un espèce de
jeu en 3d assez bien fait pour l'époque
mais par contre tout élan je sais pas si
j'ai un problème ou si j'ai chopé
l'édition troisième âge ou ou que je me
déplace sur règles de ces espèces de
scooter pour personnes âgées est là mais
a même pour faire tes courses on dirait
une mamie
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors vous pouvez aller plus vite quand
même pour ça y'a la voiture mais bon
alors attends c'est moi ou où c'est
vraiment une toute petite voiture
monsieur grenier non ces deux rues plus
loin de la mission dont vous pouvez
jouer ou kyle reese ou de terminator l'a
donc moi j'ai pris le terminator et je
dois tuer sarah connor mais là j'ai
quelques problèmes
vraiment sérieusement et ses palais
c'est une ninja
c est ce que moi je vis ou à la haye ce
que je vis très mal
ou est ce que le jeu est complètement
mal foutu la merde comment ce que je
peux la rate et je suis genre un 2000 m
[Musique]
concernant les jeux sur consoles
classiques on va commencer par le genèse
de terminator sorti en 92 adapté du
premier film terminator
ce qui est très con quand même parce que
le deuxième film terminator est sorti en
alors donc d'après la démo du jeu quand
vous laissez l'écran titre tournée il
faut lancer une grenade dans le vide
sauter ici et mourir comme une merde
voilà merci démo du jeu on peut toujours
compter sur toi de rien donc le jeu aux
non [ __ ] les égouts sérieusement déjà
l'habitude des internes au moins le
niveau 3 pour plus avoir d'idées
voila c'est direct les égouts haut
niveau le cliché numéro un du jeu vidéo
le film parle d'un futur apocalyptique
avec une guerre entre des machines des
humains et avec au milieu des voyages
dans le temps et tout ce qu'ils ont
trouvé à [ __ ] en premier c'est des
égouts et c'est pas du pinaillage 1
prenez les autres jeu terminator
toujours au début c'est la guerre tu es
dehors ça tire ça te met dans l'action
mais là non là tu arrives c'est moche
déjà disons le et on a en 92 c'est à
dire en fin de vie de la console tous
les plus beaux jeux de la nes sont déjà
sortis et laver ça manque de tout mais
c'est déjà la musique qu'ils manquent
des notes qua non parce que il ya trois
noeuds plein
[Musique]
comment ça se passe dans ce cas là en
fait à la création du jeu attendant les
oies en fait j'étais juste en train de
vérifier si vos claviers était bien
manger et oui il marchait bien et d'une
manière générale et je finirai dessus
pour le son mais le soul design de ce
jeu c'est à dire les bruitages en dehors
de la musique c'est l'austérité [ __ ] à
cesser le plan de rigueur et je saute ya
pas de son jeu meurt il n'y a pas de son
jeu tuer un ennemi ya pas de son et pour
le reste
ouais mais [ __ ] mais c'est le futur
assez la guerre envoyés du son des
explosions je n'ai pas fait quelque
chose
et venez pas me dire que c'est pas
possible de faire mieux dans l'ambiance
de guerre avait la version game boy a
fait dix points mieux c'est pas censé
être de robots qui se suicide dans un
monde avec 12 l'une terminator bon bref
le niveau est assez simple comme j'ai
dit vu que les terminator se suicide
devant vous
[Musique]
enfin bref ce qui vous tuera dans ce
niveau de toute façon ça ne sera jamais
les ennemis ça sera les contrôles déjà
tout le jeu se fait avec un décalage sur
le saut quasi permanent à cause de cette
animation bizarre là qui se joue quand
j'appuie sur le bouton
mais là où ça devient vraiment de la
merde c'est si tu coupes le ca avec une
des ide box les plus dégueulasses que
j'ai jamais vu combo guard ça s'est il
était légal s'il ya but la [ __ ] à ce
n'est plus un problème de xbox là mais
non là je suis un fantôme et je passe à
travers les murs
cette xbox et répugnante si vous n'êtes
pas précisément sur le centre exact de
votre xbox c'est à dire entre vos deux
pieds vous traverserez les plateformes
et même des fois si vous êtes bien
voulait traverser quand même
vous avez vraiment pas le luxe de gâcher
des vies comme ça parce qu'on est loin
la fin et surtout plus le jeu avance
plus on t'enlève des trucs j'ai plus
d'armes
j'ai plus d'armes [ __ ] et dans tous
les jeux plus tu avances dans les
niveaux plus on te file des trucs c'est
pas des armes des objets des bénévoles
pour t'amuser
mais non il ici les objets on te les
enlève avait pas parfait mais en plus je
me suis fait tuer par une goutte d'eau
bien vous êtes sûr qu'on a bien fait
d'envoyer ce mec pour sauver le passé si
vous êtes assez courageux vous pouvez
arriver jusqu'au niveau du commissariat
qui est le 4e ou 5e chez plus à huy au
passage notez le travail sur l'animation
de ses ennemis la caisse qu'ils ont
oublié de le programmer ce niveau
d'incompétence advient artistique donc
ce niveau du commissariat c'est un peu
le symbole de ce jeu en fait déjà
silence vivement le concert de cette
musique aux video games live
gt gt nettoyer mon clavier avec un
chiffon droit dont il était bien propre
cette musique ses ennemis ce niveau non
ce jeu
tout ça ça doit faire partie d'une
initiation d espèce de rite de passage
pour accéder au bouddhisme et à la paix
intérieure que c'est la seule
explication
regarde ça regarde le ton je regarde les
[ __ ] de 400 francs quitte à dépenser
où ils sont 1 2 3 je me baisse 2,3 m s 1
yeah
suivant ce jeu c'est une [ __ ]
d'anésthésie général c'est de la merde
en barquettes et de l'extrait de
tristesse concentré c'est nul je joue
souvent à des jeux nullement - c'est une
amie qui se passe des trucs ça là c'est
comme si une partie de la joie du monde
était morte et ne reviendrai jamais en
plus scènes interminables le niveau dure
des plombes à des portes à explorer par
tout a plus d'armée il ya des amis tous
les 4 m or tu es mois comporte pitié au
monde mais la laisse est du commissariat
elle est tellement cool dans le film
mais là ils réussissent à me la faire
détester et la solution de ce niveau
c'est des piles
c'est débile au beau milieu du niveau tu
ramasses quoi c'est quoi une calculette
une caisse enregistreuse je sais pas en
tout cas ça va là dans la case avec
l'icône de bon ben ok alors tu peux la
balance et contre les murs sur les
ennemis ça sert à rien
et bien la solution elle est ici dans ce
trou parce que dans le monde terminator
les caisses enregistreuses avec des
icônes de bombes vol et peuvent servir
de plateforme
mais allez vous faire mettre thèmes et 5
secondes cinq secondes ça vous aurez
pris de changer l'icône de la bombe et
vous espérez je continue à me flageller
avec ça peut mettre ta vu ça franchement
regarde plutôt à réduire ces conneries
surtout c'est que tu peux le chier en
plus regardent ça là je viens de la
balancer dans le bon trou mais il faut
la lancée là est pas là parce que sinon
des flottes pas évidemment c'est quoi
votre problème les mecs quoi vous voulez
faire une plateforme volante ok mais
super très bien faites le mais pourquoi
est-ce que vous lui faites une apparence
de calculette qui se rangent dans la
case bond
comment est ce que tu veux que c'était
une grande erreur
c'était de rassembler nous sommes en
1993 toujours aucun problème de dette
publique a signalé et la guerre au
proche orient est bientôt finie tout de
suite quatre heures de clips musicaux
sur la sixième chaîne sera meilleure dès
les années 90 top délire mégalo rouve
[Musique]
il n' à ce sujet en plus non pas du tout
il est pas d'asie pue la merde
mata jazzy de pas dire grand mère merde
à les jeux suivants terminator 2 sur
megadrive donc le jeu débute par une
petite intro comme dans le film où le
terminator entre dans un bar et vol les
vêtements et là le jeu commence vous
savez je me souviens de tous ces films
qui parlent de voyage dans le temps où
on te dit de faire attention à l'effet
papillon et que le moindre changement
dans le passé pour et massivement
affecté le futur non parce que là
l'anc mais le
mais non je me trompe en fait de
regarder cedeno fatale world a donc ce
mec là va bien en fait
ne vous inquiétez pas ça n'est pas
mortelle bref voilà donc cette première
mission nous demande de chercher
l'adresse de john connor le petit gars
sont contents protégée tentent de
manière aléatoire parfois vous pouvez la
voir dans la cabine téléphonique
ce qui a du sens parfois elle peut
tomber dans la poche d'un vieux motard
de 45 ans ce qui a du sens aussi mais
c'est dégueulasse
et une fois que vous avez abattu environ
2000 personnes y compris des serveuses
complètement innocente vous trouver
l'adresse ce qui vous permet d'avancer
au niveau 2 vous savez ce qu on était
bien
sachant que vous êtes envoyé par john
connor dans le futur pour sauver john
connor dans le passé john connor ou
habitiez vous quand vous aviez dix ans
20 48 rue de la boustifaille pourquoi
[Musique]
parlons un peu du jeu maintenant alors
on va oublier les premières secondes on
voit que visiblement vous terminator
être incapable d'assumer un mec en moins
de 5 ou peu la baisse quand même mais
heureusement vous ramassez rapidement
votre mes armes
le gameplay est simple j'avance je tire
éventuellement je peux accomplir et
sauter mais ça sert à rien c'est simple
mais en réalité c'est trop simple c'est
même simpliste tu peux pas courir tu
peux pas faire deux roulettes pour
esquiver les coups par exemple du coup
t'as aucun moyen de ne pas prendre des
dégâts en permanence ya tellement
d'ennemis qui arrivent de partout en
permanence un vrai génocide
et ton personnage bouge et se retourne
très lentement ce qui fait que tu peux
rien faire vraiment pour éviter de te
faire touche était constamment en train
de prendre des coups du coup tu peux
même avoir les meilleurs réflexes du
monde si tu connais pas par coeur les
emplacements des objets à ramasser dans
les niveaux
ils sont impossibles à finir parce que
tu tomberas forcément à court de vie
avant d'arriver au bout bon après
concernant le gameplay le jeu va
alterner entre deux phases les phases où
tutu des trucs et les phases où les
trucs se tue sur toi oh [ __ ] c'est
toujours dur de décrire à quel point les
contrôles d'un jeu sont mauvais sang y
jouer mais est ce que le fait que ma
moto fait n'importe quoi là ça vous aide
[ __ ] mais bougez merde dans cette
partie à peine vous effleurez du doigt
une touche de votre manette que votre
moto part à 90 degrés dans la direction
vous appuyer
qu'est ce que vous faites là pour que
ces demandes de futurs mois maniabilité
de satan à droite jeudi à droite c'est
pas vrai mais merde de merde mais je
fais pas exprès l'a sérieusement
j'essaye réellement de rouler droit à
pour de vrai regardez ça cette manette
elle est tellement sensible conduire et
je suis complètement bourré la bon la
physique de la voiture est ici plus
proche des autos tamponneuses que de
vrais bagnole mais bon on est en 93 et
on va pardonner ça par contre pourquoi
est-ce que tout explose dans ce monde
qu'elle est présente être avec
terminator qui vient pour protéger le
passé en lui exposant l'accueil ou les
plantes s'explose la brochure
télécommande arts plastiques avec les
phrases du trailer m
ce jeu c'est l' inverse du premier jeu
sur nes sur nes était censé se passer
dans un futur apocalyptique avec la
guerre majeure
il n'y avait rien c'était la mort du fun
et là c'est sans espace et dans notre
époque et il ya tout qui peut être quand
tu tire dessus ce serait rigolo si ça ne
faisait pas perdre à bâle de vie à
chaque fois que tu es à côté [ __ ] ce
meuble et c'est là où on range les slips
pourquoi ça explose de vatra jamais je
suis un leader de la résistance
oh merde
cette technique ceux qui nient ou si tu
les as lu et là moi
dis-moi comment tu t'appelles sébastien
g chez mon copain de grenier pour lire
des romans de balzac en écoutant une
drire ile en mer la mission du andré
rieu faudra vraiment que je t'ai duc
tires tu peux me dire mr ouai si vous
voulez
[Musique]
dis tu as soif
ouais à la marche super forme
tu prends tu veux t'en passer bientôt
donc nous sommes dans le troisième
niveau est donc ici nous sommes dans la
maison de john connor ici la mission est
de trouver une photo de john pour savoir
à quoi il ressemble à quoi ressemble y
est vous quand vous aviez droit ça
suffit mais dans les questions 1 des
mers de toi merde aussi le premier
endroit où tu affrontes le t1000 qui
finalement est pas plus fort que les
autres mais que tu croises et et c'est
assez dommage parce qu'encore une fois
il ya tellement d'ennemis partout tout
le temps que bien des fois tu fais même
pas gaffe si dans le tas des trucs qui
explose
il n'y a pas un robot du futur ou pas
une fois la photo récupérée on arrive au
niveau suivant où l'on croise john
connor dans des magasins avec des
magasins qui s'appelle magasin c'est
cohérent et enfin nous voilà avec le
gamin qu'on doit amener allez tu viens
john connor je suis sûr qu'il va être
super facile à convaincre ici se passe
autour de lui
comme je disais je suis là pour te
protéger
[ __ ] mais il fait quoi là aller mais
vient [ __ ] alors mais sérieux toner
cadel est criblé de balles est de même
plus marcher
vidéo [ __ ] il va pas venir ce conte
dans le film à peine il est entre
aperçoit le terminator de loin qui
s'enfuit direct et là il ya le t1000 qui
vient de se changer à côté de lui avec
une fusillade de mme allan et elle il
bouge pas et pendant ce temps là les
gens continuent à faire leurs courses
lors jolene 37
dre bouchard
après je vous avoue que plus tard je me
suis rendu compte qu'en fait on pouvait
aussi ne pas tirer sur les gens ce qui
fait que les gardes ne tire pas dessus
ouais je sais bien que ça se passe aux
usa mais bon on donne désolé si ça me
semblait un peu con quand même vu la
posture de ton perso je ne suis pas
dangereux
et vous savez ce qui m'énerve dans ce
jeu c'est ça la cette situation de merde
à t-elle les ennemis ils ont tendance
tout le temps en fait à foncer sur toi
et à ceux retrouvés collés sur ton canon
du coup tu as plus moyen de leur tirer
dessus sauf en recul en leur tournant le
dos et donc quand en prenant bien plein
les fesses quand on regarde cette
situation
pourquoi on avait d'ailleurs le futur
pourquoi ces [ __ ] de cons il vient
pas au john connard là tu te bouges
pourquoi tu mets ah ouais ok ok là ok
d'accord alors ok je suis débile
il faut juste en fait dans les options
passer le curseur sur wii bon ok ok je
suis con mais ça aussi c'est qu'on ait
voulez vous avancez dans le jeu oui ou
non évidemment je vais dire oui et c'est
quoi l'alternative du conte un
terminateur vous êtes là pour m'épauler
non pas après j'ai pas parlé de tout et
dans chaque niveau vous avez aussi des
objets du futur a récupéré en plus de
votre mission normale
comment c'est arrivé je sais pas
peut-être qu'ils ont profité du vortex
temporel ouvert pour jeter les poubelles
a même temps on va savoir
bon je vais être honnête ce jeu n'est
pas une purge absolue faut le
reconnaître il est juste profondément
frustrant est clairement horriblement
dur
je veux dire par an chez votre cerveau
merde comment est-ce que quiconque pour
réussir à finir ça il ya qu une seule
vie et pas continuer je jouais un robot
du futur pas un coréen il ya des trucs
que je peux pas faire et ta soeur va
mourir un peu
et qu'est-ce qui fait même dans la
morgue et ridicule je meurs est la
victime encore tout doucement mais je
revis mais non c'était une dernière de
zèle de vie et je me perds cruel
désespoir ou une maman et ses bons et
mon cerveau il vomit hallyday recommencé
depuis le début donc ça y'est basta pour
moi
et tu auras qu'arranger la console
tonnes
[Musique]
assez dur mais comment veux tu passes et
sayad est effectué sur tout partout ces
menus les jeux vidéo
[Musique]
mais moi ma clope petit on va se la
donner grave c'est n'importe quoi
la voiture elle est incontrôlable et le
boss ressemble à ma semaine ce jet
merdique mais faute de goût pur et purée
fut fait
alta vista point fr
[Musique]
ça c'est métal et tu joue à la nintendo
ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
e